it's a pretty place i won't be going
today sorry temperatures are a reminder
that it's pretty for many of us summer
vacation season
is here more than 47 million americans
plan to travel in cars and planes over
this holiday weekend
the vast majority will hit the road
despite gas prices jumping nearly a
dollar
a gallon from last year the ceo and
founder of the points guy brian kelly
joins us now with advice
and ideas to help plan our summer trips
good morning to you for having me
so most people are going to be driving
if you're getting away by road this
weekend when should you leave
yeah right now five minutes yesterday
whether it's by plane or by road as
early as possible because as the day
goes on it just gets more and more
crowded and the normal rush hour times
of
they no longer exist you know you can be
on the road at noon
and it's jam-packed so the earliest is
the best yeah it says today before noon
worse is four to five oh yeah okay so
and if you don't yet have a place to go
and you want to rent something is there
really anything out there there is you
know people are canceling their plans
left and right so if you are vigilant
you can absolutely still get deals you
know so even if you searched a month ago
and you couldn't find something good
never hurts to check
but on the flip side even if you have a
place i still recommend checking because
what's happening with this hot housing
market is
rental home owners are selling their
places yeah i know
multiple friends who have had their
vacation tossed up in the air because
the owner's like sorry i couldn't
resist this offer all cash offer on my
rental home so
what's your best advice while traveling
with covet you know
some states say you have to have covet
testing before you come
if you're leaving the country or coming
back to the country checking into hotels
how are you feeling because
i was at the airport brian for the first
time in over a year and a half
and it made me so nervous yeah there
were so many people i got lost going to
baggage claim
i felt like you know what happened to
you gail you used to know how to travel
yeah well that was
i was very unnerved by that people are
rusty that's the first thing
okay people are also ornery there's more
flight attendants
attacks people you know southwest flight
attendant got hurt yes knocked down
however it's not all that bad but what i
would say is everyone if you're
traveling
today check your reservations even if
it's for next week
because the airlines are at capacity you
know there's a huge labor shortage
that's the number one theme of travel
you know you can stay to fancy hotel and
not even get you know housekeeping so
understand that travel today even though
people are traveling it's not the same
as pre-pandemic
so check your reservation to make sure
that they haven't changed the time or
canceled it outright
also check your passport i'm taking my
mom on a
mother-son trip to germany and she just
told me oh wait my passport expires in a
month
sorry to throw you under the bus mom but
you know people they but get your mom a
passport well no and actually here's
actually tricky right now
it is tricky however if you contact your
local congress person they can expedite
it
which is a little hacking yes so
hopefully fingers crossed that happens
but so back to you it's safe to travel
i'm really serious about covet
precautions you should be taking as
you're traveling look if you're
vaccinated you know in the u.s we have
good vaccines
yeah um so yeah the most people are
traveling domestically you know hawaii
has been the hardest place to travel to
just last night the governor announced
starting july 7th if you're vaccinated
no need for all the crazy testing
regimen
uh europe is open however i know i've
got two europe trips coming up
however just last night portugal
announced a new curfew because of the
delta variant
so i think what you need to remember is
you know while we've made great progress
in the u.s most of the world
is not vaccinated and this delta variant
is a concern
so my number one tip use your frequent
flyer miles because you can cancel your
award tickets
free of charge what about when you get
to the location and you have to rent a
car
what can you tell us about that oh
there's like a car rental apocalypse
yeah i mean people are renting u-hauls
because they show up and there's no cars
left
and they're only 19.99 but if you're if
you're vaccinated that's the best
uh best protection if you want to travel
travel get get vaccinated bottom line
yeah ask for rental cars double check
your reservation i recommend book
directly with the car rental agency
don't get cute and try to get a good
deal through some random website because
when it comes time to cancel
reservations
they're going to honor the ones that are
booked directly and also join their
loyalty program so your information is
loaded in advance
you don't have to wait in a four-hour
line when you arrive you know at your
destination
all right so there are still deals to be
had yeah i mean the best deals this
summer
are to europe uh you have to take a
little bit of a risk level but i'll tell
you what the pictures
i mean the louvre the mona lisa has 30
people in front of it milling around
it is a once in a lifetime opportunity
to go to the trevi fountain with just a
handful of people so if you have that
risk level europe's amazing all right
just be ready to and if you're feeling
at home right now get in the car and
leave
time to go you're late you can wait till
after the show though
ryan kelly thank you